given what you were just saying about
the but and and forgive me for trying to
interpret we were saying but the but the
risk you perceived that the risk of this
position has actually gone down recently
because of the performance of the
company that's right because the tactics
that you've been employing and what you
believe is happening with the government
investigations is actually just just
gaining traction and they're running out
of victims so how does that does that
change in any way how you plan to manage
this position going forward over the
next several months early into 2015 so
we had a bunch of put options expiring
in January we thought we've spent the
last several months extending those
options all the way into 2016 as far as
2016 but a staggered over time I think
this will be a 2015 event the implosion
of the company I think worst-case early
2016 what gives me confidence the
company has a billion 150 million of
debt that comes to on early March of
2016 they are not going to be able to
refinance that credit facility they do
not have hard assets to provide security
you know the banks that provided that
facility provided it before the
government investigations before all the
revelations I encourage if I were a
lender to the company i would encourage
them to watch a few hours of a website